airpods Max 2. when are they coming out
how much will they cost and should you
wait to buy one or should you buy a pair
of airpods Max right now if you can
actually find a pair well today I'm
going to talk about all of that
including some new leaks and the airpods
sport that was rumored to come out with
a lighter design for a lower price now
earpods Max are one of Apple's weirdest
products people asked for this for a
while Apple actually created it and then
they priced them at 550 dollars which
shocked the whole world because they're
just insanely expensive now the crazy
thing is when they came out they did get
some great reviews they did have a few
issues but reviewers liked them but
regular people didn't really want to buy
them when Apple announced them they got
a bunch of attention here in Google
Trends you guys could see that massive
Spike but then the interest dropped Like
a Rock to almost nothing people
complained that they were too heavy some
people said that there's condensation
issues inside of the headphones they get
too hot and a lot of people just thought
that they look straight up
ugly and they wouldn't want to wear it
out but the weird thing is if we take a
look at what has been happening in the
last two years the interest went from
very low and it slowly started climbing
and climbing up till now where if we
take a look at the last year even though
we're in times where everything's
getting much more expensive people can
afford to spend less money the actual
interest in the airpods max is steadily
going up where usually a product goes
down in interest over time maybe it's
because of good sales that were out
there or maybe it's because a lot of
celebrities would walk around outside
with them more people saw them and it
became more of a fashion trend now
what's crazy is that now there are a
bunch of accessories that people are
making for the airpods crazy stuff like
this they could buy cool metallic things
3D printed sides even this attachment
which makes them look like earmuffs
which honestly these kind of look like
just putting them on people are buying
and look in the last 24 hours over 20
people looked at this it is clear that
people are really liking the air pods
and they are actually starting to sell
well now with their original airpods
when those came out people would make
fun of them if you have them they said
it looks weird with those stems but then
it became a fashion statement which is
kind of what's happening right now the
only thing is that I would not recommend
buying a pair of airpods Max right now I
think that is a bad idea for a few
reasons now recently we had a leak
something that was in the beta version
of iOS where we have references of new
airpods with specific model number and
another model number for the case now
some people said this could be a new
version of the airpods pro but having
USB type-c built in and since this is
included in the latest beta that usually
happens shortly before a new pair of
airpods come out but airpods Pro 2 came
out very recently and typically it only
makes sense to release those when we
have a new iPhone now if this is a pair
of airpods pro well the only reason to
update it would be to add USB type-c
instead of lightning but I think
personally that if Apple were to do this
it would have made sense to add USB
type-c back when they launched them just
a little bit ago now some other people
are saying that there is a better chance
that this is a new pair of airpods Max
and a new case to replace this little
bra I think that makes much more sense
if we take a look at the update schedule
for earpods from the first generation
airpods to the second gen we had just
over two years about two years and four
months since the actual release date and
the same thing from the second gen
airpods to the third gen airpods and
between airpods Pro that cycle took less
than three years to update now the only
thing that has come out about two and a
half years ago were the airpods Max and
with that Ming chiqua recently said that
there are new airpods Max incoming and
he even said where they are going to be
assembled and by who now we had many
leaks of airpods Max Sport which would
be a lighter cheaper version we even had
the weight listed for it it's a slightly
smaller ear pads uh 400 or 399 dollar
price made out of plastic and even
saying that's going to support silicone
on it which would be like a rubberized
finish now personally I think that would
be excellent but we also had some
reports saying the Apple canned that
development because they didn't like how
it turned out and the quality so we'll
see if that actually happens we also
have leaks of airpods light cheaper ones
so it does make sense but if airpods
started selling much better and people
started paying higher prices then that
might be one reason not to release those
now with that what is wrong with the
original airpods Max and why does Apple
need to update these and I think they
definitely need to well first off
Apple's making a huge push in lossless
audio high resolution audio but
unfortunately these cannot stream them
and even if you connect them with the
cable it still goes through the
processing chips here and you don't have
a regular direct connection which is why
if these are dead you can't just plug
them in and use them you have to have
them charged so I think that just makes
sense to fix that and with that since
the iPhones are going to be heading
towards USB type c we have to get rid of
that lightning connector and update that
as well and with that it'd be nice to
just have a digital connection with just
a regular USB type-c cable and be able
to use it wired with higher quality now
the biggest complaint I would say is
this case they need to replace this I
never use it because it sucks and with
that the active noise cancellation even
though it is really good for most cases
my airpods Pro 2 actually do a better
job now with the new chip the new
processing than the airpods max so I'm
using these less and less so those would
all be excellent updates and a great
reason to update these now what about
the price well as far as the price I
think 550 dollars was still too
expensive and that's why they're often
on sale and since Apple dropped the
price of the homepod by 50 bucks I think
a MSRP of 499 would encourage more
people to buy them with that regular
price and then they could go a little
bit lower for sales with companies if
they need to so that would be a nice
little reduction and finally to answer
one of the main questions when will they
be coming out well I showed off that
leak in the beta version of iOS that
usually doesn't happen too far ahead
from what a product launches and I think
airpods Pro makes sense in September but
with airpods Max to release them
sometime around WWDC would make sense to
me personally and one big thing to back
that up is actually looking at Apple's
listing for these if we take a look you
cannot just buy them and have them
delivered quickly the earliest is April
26th to May 3rd before they were in
stock everywhere all the time now not
only that to buy at my local store that
is May 4th but if I go in and I put in a
major city like Seattle which has a ton
of people living there a ton of stores
airpods Max is not available at any of
them and this is typically what we see
right before Apple updates a product
line we've seen it with MacBooks we've
seen it with iMacs with other products
they stop making them and then if you
order one you'll have to wait a while
and then they could release an updated
one so if they're doing that we could
even see that sooner so I think it makes
a whole lot of sense to update these the
two and a half year timestan lines up
with the previous air pods and they have
a really good reason to do that because
of popularity kicking up you release a
new model and then a lot more people get
interested you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]